so the actual question is a bit more
wordy but I've just given you the guts
of it right now the first thing I want
to note is when you have a look at this
first slide right it is V squared on the
left hand side and then it has a
quadratic in X on the right hand side
now that seems close to this but but
kind of not quite do you notice in this
result we proved over here which this is
an example of it right there's an x
squared term there's a constant term
there's no X term there's no single X
okay so why is there a single X bless
you here well when we went and proved
this result what was the starting point
it was this guy but we noted this is the
most simple kind of simple harmonic
motion because it's movement its center
is about the origin x equals zero right
if I don't have movement around the
origin about the origin rather I have to
put in this factor here right now if we
went through this entire process all
over again and went through the
integration and substituted a particular
value in for the extreme of motion if
your center of motion isn't about the
origin you end up having an extra term
flying around okay so that's why it's
there that's something which you can
sort of tweak to say oh it doesn't look
as simple as it normally does it doesn't
factor eyes out so neatly it mustn't
have a center about the origin so just
have that far in the back of your mind
now let's have a think about this
question part one where does the
particle rest where does it stop okay
what can you tell me about velocity if
the particle is at rest velocity will be
equal to zero right that's what at rest
means by definition so I can solve this
equation for when V equals zero and I'm
going to get something for X go ahead
and do that it's not complicated it's a
quadratic you can solve this to
so you got your quadratic here you went
ahead and you solved then it's they've
mercifully giving you a nice neat thing
to factorize and you come out with this
now Aryans ask me a nice question which
is you know should I say and instead of
or hmm the question is where is the
particle at rest it's true the particle
is at rest at negative six and it's also
at rest at two but here's a tricky thing
right you know when you get asked an
area you know here's a here's a function
what's the area underneath the curve
like so right you got a function like
that what would you do what knowledge
would you pull on to evaluate that area
it's under a curve so you would use a
definite integral right so you might say
Oh a equals a definite integral from
here to whatever of that thing right now
when you go ahead and you solve this dot
dot dot and you get a number at the end
okay does that they have units on it hmm
you have to be super careful it's a
pretty fine new ones to call out but if
this is an integral integrals do not
have units in the same way that
derivatives do not have units it's just
all numbers right units come in when I
say ah but the thing that I was trying
to solve with this is this that's the
object I was after if the object is
something different like say this if I
was trying to solve for a solid of
revolution I would still have an
integral and the integral would still
have no units but I would say I
introduced this integral in order to
find a volume so I would have different
units along with that cubic units right
now this thing here this equation here I
have introduced it to solve this
question in the context of what I've
just written here this equation X is a
variable it can't be two different
things at the same time it's this or
it's that and it can't be two things
simultaneously
but then I can say I've introduced this
equation to solve that question so if I
wanted to word it I would say therefore
the particle is at rest at negative six
and A two and and though use of and make
sense in that context okay in this case
it won't really matter because they're
looking for these numbers and they're
okay with that
but yeah
wanted to know the exact answer that's
why I put war there okay so part two
they now want acceleration as a function
of displacement as a function of X okay
now you've got two choices about how to
do this and I'm going to show you both
because they're quite quick write
acceleration as a function of X look up
here right just see this thing this is V
squared right hmm V squared
go back to the very first thing you
wrote down today right you know the
acceleration is quite closely connected
to V squared it's not quite V squared
though it's half V squared that the
acceleration is connected to ya so if I
don't have half way squared here that's
okay it's not difficult to make it half
V squared so I'm gonna say multiply
everything by 1/2 that gives me what
does it give me 12 minus 4 X minus x
squared is that okay so there's 1/2 V
squared
I like 1/2 V squared because it's so
closely connected to acceleration all I
have to do is differentiate with respect
to X that's the result that I've been
using for this all of this to prove all
of this right so all I have to do is
differentiate with respect to X which
gives me what hello look yep I don't
have to look at that that's okay that
becomes negative 4 that becomes minus 2x
that's acceleration as a function of X
there is one other way that I could do
this there and it calls on your
knowledge of simple harmonic motion
right remember when we first wrote this
down I said hey look at that red guy
what's that doing there that means the
center of motion is no longer the origin
right now we already have in our working
we already have confirmation of that can
you have a look at the working that I
have on the board it's not that much
what information that I've written down
in my working tells me the center can't
be 0 yeah you found the extremes of
mission and they're here right if it was
like negative 6 and 6 that's where it
stopped you're like oh it's symmetrical
if it was negative 2 & 2 you'd say oh
it's symmetrical but it's not
symmetrical these are the extremes of
emotion so what's the center of motion
it's halfway between these guys right so
it's the average which
is x equals negative 2 that is the
center so I can say I can confirm for
myself I know that acceleration this is
X double dot Yeah right
acceleration for a simple harmonic
motion object that isn't about the
origin is minus N squared X minus B
where B is my center of motion ok now if
this is what the center of motion is
what what X minus B become X minus
negative 2 so this part would be X plus
2 do you agree okay now have a look
minus N squared X have a look up here
have a look up here right where is that
- end going to come from where could it
possibly be have a think right when
you've um when you had a look at your
original equations right you'd get minus
N squared X and some other stuff in here
for V squared right well have a look
when you factorize out the only thing to
factorize out of x squared is just that
guy there you see that that is the minus
N squared so you can say oh it's just
going to be minus 2 now does that does
that match you have a look - too much
more you just expand and you'd get there
right so if you can interpret oh I know
where the center is I know what this end
will be it's actually root 2 in this
case you can read that off the result
that you know already ok so it's a nice
confirmation last question maximum speed
part three ok there you have some
choices about this maximum speed where
is it going to occur well all the
information I've been doing here it all
has to do with acceleration right
I used where was it at rest by finding
out when the acceleration is when when
you're going to be at the ends here I
differentiated with respect to X to get
acceleration so what piece of
information do you know about the
acceleration at those points we have
maximum speed
what would the acceleration be when
you're at maximum speed the acceleration
should be
zero right think about that again joy
yourself a quick and dirty sort of there
we go I know the center is somewhere
else but I'm just thinking about how
fast it moves here is where you're going
slowest right whoops which is where you
have the maximum acceleration in the
opposite direction you're like oh I'm
really far away positive so I get
negative acceleration I'm really far
away negative so I get positive
acceleration but at these points here
and here and here you're not
experiencing any acceleration whatsoever
and that's when you are moving fastest
right so I'm going to say maximum speed
occurs and I'm going to encourage you to
write this sentence it doesn't take much
and it shows grant understanding of what
you're actually doing here even if the
subsequent equation you get confused by
maximum screw occurs when acceleration
is zero and you know where that happens
here's acceleration right here as a
function of displacement so I can take
all that's X double dot bla bla bla bla
bla I can find one that's equal to zero
really easily in fact so I can say minus
four minus two x equals zero minus two x
equals 4 x equals negative 2 now does
that look suspicious we wrote this down
before didn't we
we already inferred it from saying oh
your Center will be halfway between your
extremes of motion which is exactly
where your acceleration is zero so it's
kind of nice when you come from two
different angles and you like oh I have
confirmation of what I had before so
that's really good what do I do with
this was I trying to find this the
center motion no I was actually trying
to find a maximum speed which is a
velocity thing right so I'm going to
come back to this equation for V squared
V squared will equal and I need to
substitute in my chosen value of X which
gives me this mm plus 16 minus 8 that
look okay how's my substitution you
happy with that
24 plus 16 is 40 take away 8 that gives
you 32 so that's plus or minus 32 what's
the biggest square number I can pull out
of 32 I can pull out 16 so that'll
become yeah that's that which is the
square root of 16 is 4
- I was asking for maximum speed and so
I just can say it doesn't matter whether
it's positive or medium is 4 root 2 it
just so happens in this particular
question because I mean it looked the
unit's they give you are they don't give
you any unit we don't know no distance
unit no time unit so you just say
full-stop